bien malheureusement ça a déjà commencé
puisque bon on l'a évoqué un la russie
c'est le premier producteur mondial et
exportateur mondial de blé par exemple
premier exportateur mondial de gaz
deuxième exportateur mondial de pétrole
donc évidemment s'il ya une guerre en
russie avec l'ukraine notamment et si
parallèlement bloc c'est les mesures les
fameuses mesures on essaye de faire un
embargo vis-à-vis de la russie mais on a
déjà observé les prix flambent depuis de
façon incroyable assez exceptionnel
c'est à dire que on prend les cours du
blé le dernier sommet c'était en 2008
savez y avait également eu une crise à
l'époque là on est 10% au-dessus du
sommet de 2008 alors sur le pétrole
effectivement on n'a pas encore atteint
on avait un sommet en 2008 on est à 150
dollars le baril et on est monté à au
plus haut à 139 sa robe est un peu la
grande différence avec deux minutes
c'est qu'en 2008 on avait un euro fort
comme vous savez mon on paye le pétrole
en dollars quand on ramène en euros si
l'euro est fort mais c'est pas trop
grave c'était le cas en 2008 la
différence c'est la double peine c'est
qu'aujourd'hui non seulement d'un
pétrole qui est très cher mais on a
également l'euro qui baisse donc c'est
ce qui fait qu évidemment le
portefeuille des français l'inflation
tant que je signe ça peut aller marca
c'était dramatique c'est que le problème
c'est que ça vient après deux ans de
pandémie se dire que l'inflation ce
qu'on appelle l'inflation jetons c'est
l'augmentation des prix elle était à 30%
qui vient casser le pouvoir d'achat
exactement lé même là avant même la
guerre on est à 4 % 4 pour france on est
à 5 8% dans la zone euro du jamais vu
c'est historique donc ce qui veut dire
que avant même la guerre on avait déjà
une très forte inflation parce que
justement localisation pour ceux qui
nous écoutent augmentation des prix y
ont effectivement des prix et donc en
fait c'est très simple si les prix
augmentent mais que vos revenus vos
salaires n'augmentent pas comme les prix
vous perdez du pouvoir d'achat donc
c'est exactement ce qui est en train de
s'observer aujourd'hui par contre bon je
veux pas affoler les foules mais le vrai
problème c'est que malheureusement pour
l'instant on n'a pas encore la
répercussion de la hausse des prix de
ces dernières semaines sur notre
quotidien et ça va évidemment arriver ça
veut dire qu'on peut avoir très vite
aujourd'hui en france par exemple une
inflation qui monta à 5% en moyenne mais
attention là où ça devient dangereux
c'est que cette inflation les 13
inégalitaire parce qu'en fait tu pourras
en france vraiment pas en moyenne si
vous voulez l'alimentaire par exemple
ces 15 % du panier de la ménagère ça
c'est une moyenne mais comme ça on vit
pas avec des moyennes par contre pour un
ménage modeste l'alimentaire cela monte
à 30 40 % pareil pour l'énergie c'est à
peu près 8 9% en moyenne pour un ménage
modeste est remonté à 15 % à 8 % un bon
compte et aux comptes et le gasoil de la
voiture et le chauffeur sur complètement
et demi pour ça tout à fait donc 8 à 9%
mais là ça peut monter à 12 15 donc ce
qui veut dire que c'est le drame c'est
que les prix qui augmentent le plus eh
bien c'est ce qui représente le plus
important pour les ménages modestes que
touati dans un monde que je me calme
dans le temps prédit depuis 25 ans qu'il
est totalement mondialisé comment les
élites j'aime pas ce mot donc c'est de
l'ironie qui nous gouvernent n'ont pas
pu anticiper un tel choc parce qu'on
sait qu'aujourd'hui tout dépend de tout
comme jamais dans toute l'histoire de la
planète c'est ça qu'est drame allait
donc en fait on s'est tiré une balle
dans le pied si on parle je voulais le
problème alors j'irai encore en france
entre guillemets on peut protéger parce
qu'on a le nucléaire où il n'ya pas de
la france on est là et on est moins
dépendant effectivement mais faune et
l'allemagne paraît donc toujours aidé
par un même pour sa remarque est du gaz
russe tout à fait légalement pour le
gazon le gall vaut au ninja c'est
uniquement pour le gaz les allemands
dépendra 55 % du gaz russe il a fait
l'un des 5 % exactement 100 % folie
complètement ça c'est pour le gaz mais
surtout ils n'ont pas d'énergies
alternatives
c'est là qu'a été la grande erreur des
allemands aujourd'hui on va arrêter le
nucléaire donc si vous n'avez pas de
nucléaire faire autre chose donc votre
électricité votre énergie dépend de plus
en plus justement du gaz et par
définition que c'est un problème de
philosophie pour des raisons morales on
se punit économiquement une certaine
manière c'est surtout un problème encore
une fois on a fait la même erreur avec
les chinois si on lit pendant la
pandémie on n'avait pas de masque on
avait plus deux mais pas de semi
conducteurs etc du paracétamol ça c'est
une erreur si vous voulez stratégie qui
a été fait qui date des années 80 qui
était poursuit ensuite si je prends le
cas de la france nadine on veut une une
économie sans usines etc on va se
débrouiller comme ça on note des
services mais non on prend l'agriculture
française qui est une des forces de la
france ben on aurait dû effectivement
jeux développés devraient modérer qu'on
nous mette le tableau du prix du gaz et
du prix de l'essence de parce qu'on a un
tableau qui est assez affolant et
vertigineux
marqué je voudrais que vous nous donniez
votre avis là dessus quand je vous
demandais tout à l'heure jusqu'où ça
peut aller vous avez vu le pic cette
évolution sur le marché néerlandais de
que du prix du gaz
le pilote à 345 euros en cours de séance
voilà ce sur tout ce qu'ils voient c'est
que l'augmentation c'est quasiment du
6000 % sur certains de la fois depuis
mars 2020 c'est des niveaux complètement
fous ce qu'il faut savoir également
c'est que à la différence par exemple on
parlait des états unis eux ils ont
compris larnack si vous voulez c'est à
dire que les américains ils sont
aujourd'hui indépendant énergétiquement
il continue et nova nous on arrête
l'importation de pétrole russe forcément
ils en ont pas son impact examen portent
pas donc ils sont prêts mais alors moi
j'ai un peu le sentiment peut-être que
vous allez dire que c'est un côté un peu
critiques des etats-unis veulent pas
nous filer leur gaz de schiste les
américains le problème c'est que
aujourd'hui encore ça prend du temps et
à dire que on a aujourd'hui les
partenariats pendant que je prends
l'allemagne il ya des gazoducs qui vont
directement en allemagne donc si vous
arrêtez ça il faut trouver d'autres
sources qu'on va les trouver bien sûr
mais ça va prendre du temps c'est ça
l'enjeu alors on à la norvège le qatar
l'algérie bien sûr on a eu alors je
cueille rassurer effectivement ceux qui
nous écoutent quand même parce que là
vous voyez cette cette coupe comme ça là
toute droite ouais c'est évidemment
complètement anormal c'est à dire qu'on
a un aspect spéculatif qui est là tu
veux dire que si demain on l'espère tous
la guerre s'arrête où on a un accord du
mois effectivement les prix repartiront
à la baisse c'est à dire que ça sera
évidemment la bonne nouvelle est donc
non l'important sera content plus ça va
durer longtemps plus ces tensions vont
durer longtemps tous les conséquences
vont être durable sur notre économie sur
notre pouvoir d'achat dire que même si
demain la guerre s'arrête pas là
aujourd'hui tous les bateaux qui sont
bloqués effectué dans la mer noire ils
pourront pas je dirais arrivé tout de
suite là où ils doivent aller et là on
parle de la france mais si on regarde
tous les pays émergents si vous voulez
aujourd'hui qui ont besoin du blé
lafreux la flambée des cours du blé
c'est un drame